I watched V I had friends who how was he
on the uh what what was it recently
there's another Republican the Nikki
Haley thing yeah like break okay break
it down break well break the VC thing
down so am I again macroscopic view I
had friends who liked him before he ran
for president they read his book and he
was saying all these things that were
nuanced and thoughtful and then every
time I watched him in any debate or
interview or whatever he just pivoted to
these kind of talking points that I
think he thought were pandering to what
right-wing people wanted of oh they're
censoring free speech and oh he would
like he had this tweet I remember about
how Black Rock in some other financial
institution was a cartel that's like
ruining America and he goes That's why
when I'm president I'm going to make
them disband their ESG scores to not
have diversity that's forced and I'm
like you had a be you had a bar up top
and then you made it this pandering
talking point and I think you [__]
yourself and you're going to lose and I
wonder if you could do it again would
you actually be like am I garnering
attention in the right way is this
really the way I want to get where I
that's a good conversation I have with
them which is it's basically like the
Hillary thing it's like do you want to
win or do you want to help cuz we could
tell the difference like when people
want to help genuinely we're drawn to
them yeah some people aren't good at
communicating their yearning to help but
when you're a good communicator and you
genuinely want to help matter of fact
when you genuinely want to help you
don't even got to communicate that well
yeah that's why Bernie gets respect from
even people that hate him they're like
yeah I think he genuinely wants to help
I disagree with him on this that I hate
his politics disagree with how he wants
to help but he wants to help yeah and I
think that's what we're searching for
when it comes to presence and I think
that like Trump was able to do it
because our version of oh he wants a
help is by talking [__] to all the
people that we were annoyed by MH right
so I think you convince us you're like
oh wait a minute yeah I am annoyed by
traditional politicians that just
regurgitate these [__] talking
points to Pander to me this guy's kind
of out out here just making fun of him I
like that yeah but then he would says oh
I want to clean the swamp and then you
get four years to do it of course of
course what I'm what I'm saying is no no
my thing is now now that he's running
again why aren't people like oh no I'm
off you because you didn't stick to what
you said you were going to do the enemy
of your enemy is your friend I think
that's what I think I think we're just
so frustrated by what's going on like
we're frustrated by the fact that
Democrats won't acknowledge that like
Biden really ain't all there yeah like
you what I mean like he they just won't
even say yeah he ain't really all there
but don't worry we're pulling the
strings and and we got this and they
keep going like yo his policies have
done really well to be fair to them they
can't you can't be like hey guys the guy
we wanted to win sorry yeah again he's a
scarecrow unfortunately a scarecrow in
the office as an American I don't want
them to say that cuz then every other
country's coming for us exactly it's
like oh [__] they got a bird brain over
it I just how fire America is even with
a scarecrow we're still kind of killing
it we're [__] killing it yeah we're a
beautiful idea and it's executed well
most of the time but for Trump I also
think we don't ever acknowledge they're
all scarecrows that's the thing
everybody's a scare but we want our
scarecrow to dance yeah look cool and
[__] dance a little bit my boy like
listen to Outcast shoot
threes dance we need them all dancing
okay don't tell them to dance don't tell
Obama I I tell Trump to dance I'll tell
half of Obama to dance I'll tell his
mama's hat oh but like we need you to
dance for us and make us feel proud to
be American and if you're not doing that
and you're a scarecrow listen if you're
not doing that and we just hate you you
gave us something to hate today I bumped
into a friend and I could be like yo
what a [__] [__] this guy is but
when you're an old man and you're a
scarecrow one I feel bad [__] on
this old man who don't want to be there
he can't even go to the beach and relax
on his 90th birthday no he'll turn to
sand bro he'll become the Beast so it's
like like I think that's what happens I
also think with Trump we Overlook that
middle White America has not been spoken
to or spoken for had not been in a long
time they not felt it hey relax buddy no
Middle America get happy a white dog he
wants to make America
great but I think they were like finally
some even this college thing is that's
what they're all upset about how come
when [__] happens to us nobody cares
that's what Andrew was saying you guys
are always shouting out everybody those
white people don't care about the Jews
they're like yeah but what what about us
now you get it they' been told all over
the media you have white privilege your
life is great and like they're losing
jobs they're dying they got drug
epidemics finally one guy came was like
n I'm for y'all and they were like I
don't give a [__] what else you say I'll
ride with it cuz finally somebody
speaking for us and still that's the
only guy really speaking for them he's a
guy yeah I feel like now everybody's
speaking for him I feel like that's
become the Republican position like Vic
out there talking about let's get rid of
this diversity I meant the only guy with
Charisma I think yeah I think he was the
first person to swing the pend in that
dire and now all these politicians are
just like hey I represent what the
people want is this what y'all want okay
I'm dancing over here now
and yeah the Democrats haven't figured
it out bro Democrats I don't know if the
Democrats know what to
do I think they just still we have to
abide by the system and this is the way
how things go but don't you feel like
they haven't done a good job of like
curating what their people want like I
feel like they're leaning into the
extreme version of what their people
want and that extreme version exists
online but like most people I feel like
these like Center folks that are now
leaning right because of what how goofy
the Democrats have become like where is
this like kind of Centrist Democrat you
got the gay guy booty judge would take
it dude I think he would absolutely win
yeah oh
oh what did you think he was to say you
agreed to not kind of
quit yeah I think he would absolutely
win and we just yeah but I also think
Republicans are doing the same
caricature type Jud a bottom though does
that matter it does a little bit bro I
don't want my president getting [__] I
want to verle I want to versatile you
got you got to be you going get the
black vote bro yeah yeah yeah yo lowkey
bo just came out was like yo I don't get
[__] oh okay
okay my why did you say that that should
be his campaign slogan cling cheek yeah
walk his little dainty ass husband out
there like tell tell yeah put your
little skirt on yeah you got to make you
got to make the husband more feminine
100% now we need something bro all right
guys we going to take a break from this
exclusive patreon clip because I got to
tell you about the best hard dicks in
the business it's yours with blue Chu
that's right same active ingredients is
inside viagara se but this is The Chew
this one that we rock with this one that
you're going to keep your girl happy
with the girl you haven't even slept
with you're going to give her the night
of your life your wife that you've been
sleeping with for the last 10 years you
going to surprise her I'm telling you
you The Chew has got your back and
you're going to get your first month
free all you got to do is pay $5
shipping when you go to bluechew.com and
use the promo code flagrant that's it
very simple go enjoy it and let's get
back to this exclusive patreon clip join
our patreon get a new episode every
single week at patreon.com flagrant I
thought Mark cubin was running bro I
really did as soon as he sold the team I
was like it's it it's over then you saw
the casino come up you're like yeah yeah
you're that's the real reason you can't
I guess own a casino and a team I I also
think they're getting into the sports
betting I think oh the casino has a
sports book and therefore you can't be
part of it it's not legal in Texas yet
like he's plotting on he's plotting for
it to be legal yo that's how these
[__] that's what's crazy is
it's decades down the road Texas hadn't
even made medicinal weed legal I don't
think why is gambling not legal in Texas
they're super it's still very Bible Belt
like all these puritanical laws is
gambling legal Florida just got it like
right because I think in Mississippi you
got to be on the water water yeah so the
river like the casino is on or Missouri
and most of them yeah most River States
you got to be on that Lou you get on the
on the you know what's so funny this is
America we we the most funny
[__] we be cracking jokes about
these Muslim countries that put their
little uh their their casinos and [__]
and they put their like alcohol their
bars whatever they like put them on the
water and look at them trying to get
around rules and in Mississippi we doing
the exact same [__] same thingo it's
have youever aloh laws are crazy is that
a Biblical thing is gambling illegal
it's all Bible I think it's like a
puritanical but this is not like Old
Testament like gambling is illegal they
don't I don't think so I think it's an
interpretation of the Bible from like
Puritans coming over to 1800 puritanical
likew plus Old Testament a lot of them
guys are in banking anyway so how you
going to have a problem with G you can
you buy alcohol in New York on a Sunday
yeah cuz in Florida I think you can to
be that liquor stores were closed on
Sundays remember when we were younger
when I was a kid in Texas you could not
Hood well dangas were open no but I
think you couldn't buy alcohol that's
right on certain days yeah Florida it's
like before noon I think maybe they've
just recently changed that there's
people that will drive across state
lines to bet on the highway because they
get on to on their phones they can
gamble in the state over and they'll bet
on their phones a sports bet and then
they'll drive back home if they live
close like if you live close to Jersey
people are driving in to Jersey betting
over the line and then going back home
yeah and making their money so here's a
question I have for Mark cubin if we
have him on Mark cubin has been kind of
unanimously he's a rare breed he's
unanimously
loved and supported and looked at as
like a good guy billionaire and there's
like a handful right it's hard and also
a good guy billionaire that like did it
kind of ethically that's like he's
trying to do this uh making the drug
prescription drugs just like a sports
franchise that's awesome and like won a
[__] ring and they were terrible
before he got there people don't realize
a decade of being awful before he got
there like and and usually owners that
know nothing about sports suck but like
kind of a cool guy that you would want
to play for treated the players well
okay casinos are are ugly yeah and they
get a little bit they could kind of
destroy neighborhoods destroy
communities like I'm wondering if he's
balancing how he could be perceived yeah
you know like you're selling I think
he's building a sports complex where the
Arena's going to be in and then there's
a casino like a part of it'll be a
resort that has gambling in it it's like
a casino resort with got it got it got
it got it got it it's just one of those
things where it's like you know you I
think Vegas has this beautiful
perception but when you're in there you
see especially you go to some of the
shittier casinos you see these like
people who are
clearly [__] GTA 6 in there a little
bit yeah yeah there's a little GTA 6
Vibe and then what happens to his
reputation when people start going yo
this is what you're responsible for I
don't know if people care yeah he won't
put his yeah you probably right Vegas
nobody cares nobody looks at the guy at
the win as somebody yeah but they're not
as out front as Cuban Cuban is out there
now granted he left Shark Tank he might
be falling back maybe he's he's what 65
or whatever so he might just be like
it's I don't care anymore I'm G to fall
back and just be rich but bro I saw I
saw Steve wi you know the guy who owns
the win yeah uh when I was in uh Amalfi
mhm now Amalfi is is arguably the most
beautiful Coastline in the world mhm and
Steve win is
blind like big blind or little
blind good that was good that good but
like what is going on bro I used to work
at a museum Art Museum best art museum
in Florida the State Museum of Florida
yeah and uh I was working there and I
went oh there's people coming around the
corner I should be ready like whatever I
gave tours the whole thing
blind group came in fully blind with the
sticks the whole thing for what well
maybe they thought they're going to the
Met think about that they might have
told him like Hey we're in New York
right now we're going to the Met it's a
really nice museum and they were
actually in Sarasota yeah that that's
the come up that's what they should have
done with that guy send him to Rockway
been like dude a mfie that's the thing
put him on a boat anywhere he would have
heard them black people in
rock yeah send him to Jersey maybe be
like okay these are Italian enough so
what do you do like yeah I'm curious
about that you're a billionaire you got
all the [__] money in the world I
guess you still want to flex like you
still want to be where you got girls and
you want to take girls or you want to
take your family certain places take
them all right fair enough you don't
become a billionaire with that ambition
you know what I mean and it just doesn't
go
away God took your eyeballs and you're
like who needs that tell me what it's
like out there yeah exactly you become
Daredevil dude it's probably easier you
know what I mean you don't have to look
at people in the face when you fire them
when you screw them over you you think
he just lies about being blind say he's
doing a Stevie Wonder Bo Stevie's lying
yeah yeah St
that is a big black conspiracy tev1 can
see I think you can see a little bit
like I think you can see a little bit
how much there was some [__] where like
I think Shaq did something where you
like he Shaq did something and like he
saw it and this was goes way back you
have to find a clip but yeah I think
he's lying like I think he see a little
bit because to be legally blind it
doesn't mean you can't see [__] it just
means you see so bad that you can be
deemed legally blunt so he's a legally
blunt a little bit he's fake
it
whatever yeah we need to know what
legally blind is bro it's it's like a
disability thing but Steve win was in a
uh was in a defamation lawsuit and they
said that he sexually harassed someone
or like was staring like whatever and
he's like I'm legally blind I can't Lear
guys and that was his legal defense oh
so he ain't really blind he's just
playing a character BR he probably
legally blind like a doctor he probably
can't see that well I bet if you're
billionaire you can get a doctor to say
you're legally [__] blind true yeah
true yo this [__] imagine
cheating on your wife being like I
thought it was you I was staring at this
[__] like this at a restaurant
because I was confident he was legally
blind this guy's watching me watch him
have you seen the fake blind prank where
a dude will like go in the hood it's
fantastic and like he'll just be like
eating ice cream staring at some dude
the whole time just deep throwing the
ice cream and the guy will like stand up
be like yo what's up and then he puts on
his glasses and walks away with the dog
have you seen this bro it's unreal prank
or the guy with the fake dog that barks
be killing me in Brooklyn I think he he
got a fake like a cotton dog that he and
he just he walks and then when he walks
by somebody he has the glass on like
he's blind too and he
goes and people still get afraid of the
fake dog Y what did you just say sorry
sorry what did you just say sorry happy
I Dro yeah I dropped a crazy word right
yeah you ever bark at your own dog and
then the dog barks back you're like yo
do I speak dog am
I do I speaking dogs out here uh oh yo I
had a thought I don't know if we floated
this on this maybe I got it from y'all
but RFK is running he's getting 24% of
the vote is he at 24 that's what he's
pulling he's pulling in the 20s it's
crazy it's like undeniable now do you
think it's possible he's actually a
Democrat plant to be like this is the
only way we beat Trump is if you take a
lot of his votes talk all the Republican
talking points the vaccine is not real
it's not good for you blah blah blah
speak to that demographic take some of
Trump's votes and now that's the only
[__] way Biden can win oh that's fire
cuz I don't see any other way Biden wins
yeah conspiracy baby talk that [__] my
boy hold on hold on think about RFK
running he's a Kennedy this is a
Democrat Legacy and all of a sudden
there's one guy whose dad was one of the
Democrats that got killed in the 60s and
he's just not saying any Democratic okay
now here's the question yeah does he
know o dumb conspiracy what is the term
like a useful idiot useful idiot ah is
he a useful idiot because I think
sometimes these guys don't know and they
genuinely believe all this [__] but
they're kind of nurtured and pushed in a
certain direction like the CIA art thing
or like all these artists and like the
this is this is great like postmodern
era where like Jackson po were like
making can you just not know more than
me once no gu you than me one time I
think I brought you might have heard
this before you might have heard this
but like all these like like postmodern
artists were like making all this like
very abstract art throwing [__] at the
thing painting with their titties and
[__] yeah and and they were blowing up
and they were all over the world and
selling for millions of dollars and then
they found out later that the CIA was
propping it up as a cultural War tool
against Russia to be like look how free
we are we're making crazy cool [__]
people are making money being free and
the Russian Russian Art Russian
architecture is brutalist right now at
the time yeah so it's like how can we
show how much more amazing America is
you can do whatever you
want same thing so you get RFK be like
yo get in there start riing [__] up he
might not even know he might not and he
has a fake swore throat that's also
that's
throat bro give him a cop drop son if
Trump gives him a recola on the first
debate imag a go way if he goes listen I
had enough I can't it's too much I can't
listen to it just take one of these and
try to clear your [__] imagine fixes it
though then he kills R then RFK is done
you give Mara like that in a public
moment it's over his career is over he
sounds amazing that's his shot but
imagine Trump is up there do you even
believe his
voice what is this take a dude yeah yeah
that's I mean they got to sponsor him
immediately he used to be he used to be
a Democrat who RFK yeah it could be
Democrat or is he an independent I think
he's running as independent so he's
doing the Ross perau [__] and that's
smart because you can't beat Trump in a
primary this is also where I think
another miscalculation V made is that's
why I think he just wants to beat
Trump's VP and that's it like you're not
beating Trump in the primary don't [__]
he's not show into debates he's going to
win RFK I can run as independent you
can't stop me from running and I'm going
to take votes from this guy potentially
Democrats don't run as one of us start
to look like you're going away from us
you're not with us anymore talk all the
talking points that Trump's most rabid
people believe in and now you're a
legacy guy you seem like
anti-establishment super you would be
the guy that's fire if you can
take both parties though I think he's
hurting both but I think it's going to
hurt them more and I think they would
just based on the way he talks I think
they're like nah he's going to hurt them
more he's going to take more votes from
them I can't see a lot of Biden people
who were hardcore Democrats being like I
like what he's saying I can see a lot of
Hardcore trumpers being like I like what
he's saying I just feel there's a lot of
Democrats that are just like I don't
want either so they're just like I'll
vote for this guy yeah yeah we're so
disillusioned who are people looking
towards in America right now there's not
even an Entertainer that's why I think
it's perfect if hubben wants to run I
think it's exact run I think I listen
you know I love the rock but I don't
know if people want the rock to be
president bro John Stewart Stewart I
would love yo and John like with I love
John I don't think JN has the same like
I don't think he's as popular as he was
I think he's beloved especially by Our
Generation but I don't think his
popularity is there like I think
America's in this weird space where we
don't have our Figure Head our hero like
there was a moment when maybe Tom Brady
was a version of it that sounds stupid
but understand what I'm trying to say
when he was playing with Tampa Bay there
is this part of us where we are like is
he going to do the unthinkable yeah is
this guy so great that he's going to
[__] pull it off who is that now who
is the hero in the American story right
now